hey I was going bros my name is Evan
today we're gonna play Tekken I never
actually played Tekken before I play to
look a little bit of Mortal Kombat but I
thought we'd do some online matches I'm
of course going to play it the only
character you could possibly play if
you're pretty pie that's right Bob
I've been practicing for like 20 minutes
I know one [ __ ] move
it's 6 1 all right we're connecting here
we go I'm ready I'm ready to do this
[ __ ] Bob Bob's got the strength
all right we're against whatever big
titty lady got it don't no match for Bob
Bob Bob wolf Bobby's fat and so are
those tits Jesus Christ show tell ya Bob
one
okay whatever gatling come on baby oh
it's looking bad for Bob come on do the
dudes one move Bob come on Bob there any
another Bobby's angry bob is not happy
great well Tracy's alright don't worry
about it poit new strategy for bodies
there it is
come on
sister [ __ ] down [ __ ] that's it ha ha
ha bobbin spat everyone Bob it's fat oh
[ __ ] yeah no please come on come on Bob
they're ready another one [ __ ]
come on Bob don't [ __ ] up now
Roberts angry come on activate it I
don't know how to activate my [ __ ]
rage Oh for [ __ ] sake ah yeah oh I'm
Bobby's never ready to fly [ __ ] sorry
okay I'm sorry I'm saying oh no I can't
[ __ ] up now
that's it I got one move Bobby's angry
yes I got it
yeah yeah okay [ __ ] this is getting him
[ __ ] intense
come on Bob don't let me down Bob that's
[ __ ] it that's [ __ ] right
gotta get [ __ ] [ __ ]
mom yeah yes what Bob everyone that's
right that's the first match I ever
[ __ ] won I know I'm terrible at this
game like I'm not going to pretend that
I'm good but but Bob is bob is the
greatest character of all [ __ ] time I
can I can never activate the [ __ ]
rage art it's so annoying
I want bauble shirt it's so [ __ ] cool
and it's designer pants okay
all right okay we can block these never
mind come on [ __ ] I'm in the corner
Bobby's angry Bobby you don't want to
make it Bob angry oh oh [ __ ] I'm dead
that's fine that's fine Bob will live
one smart round to bob expand everyone
oh god god damn it
please I'm fine
great great
Bobby thank me now tell ya you don't
make Bob angry bro oh god okay okay
ah three it's okay we're fine okay we're
not fine we're not fine
we're not Bob needs to do something
um [ __ ] I'm so fun oh how you like that
are you like that boy how you like that
how you like that [ __ ] ha ha ha
Bob that's right Bob
come on Bob you got this that's right
the one move I know how to kiss yeah oh
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
it's fun it's fun to do the meatballs
with the meat do the meatball Bob now
with it
oh [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god how did that come on
Bob come on bud
come on but you're Swedish meatball Bob
another one another one please another
one yes dick can i but that's right Bob
your [ __ ] angel goddamn the
strengthing Bob the power never
underestimate a good Bob
never underestimate a good Bob I'm on a
[ __ ] roll who's this little kitty cat
I got two wins on my belt [ __ ]
I'm probably ready to go pro in this
game now
I [ __ ] love Bobby such a [ __ ] bad
character he's like a ginger fat blond
Americans but he's still strong and fast
oh god what is it cancer
World War I can't look to this boy oh
god what is she oh oh
ruining the floor
that's right sit the [ __ ] down [ __ ] got
him nope no Bobby's angry he'll make
Bobby angry fat all right whatever
same thing come on Bob
no damn ixi high for a fat man that's it
okay Oh Oh Bob is angry
come on Matt release your anger Bob I
[ __ ] up Oh
ah you got [ __ ] Nick ha ha ha ha
hell yeah
Oh God [ __ ] it doesn't hit anymore
yeah yeah ok
I got you thank ring oh [ __ ] no way I'm
fine I'm fine I'm not fine god damn it
god [ __ ] damn it come on I can't lose
man not to this face please Bob your
designer pain filling the spring for
them your perfect hair your perfect
complexion you have that's it that's
[ __ ] it you're the meatball slide
[ __ ]
oh oh oh Bobby's angry doesn't matter
this is college this is really [ __ ]
close
oh come on Bob you're fat Bob oh I try
to do to the roll come on oh my god yeah
oh yeah got that [ __ ] [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] awesome can we see that again
yes I want a [ __ ] wrong I'm the best
I'm the best player of life I take it
back I mean Bob it all right here we go
no just fast you're Billy do this time
this is Spanish dude now let the show
big kids show him your boy sexy body Bob
what going in now I know a Norton you
move never mind
that's it that's it do the karate
stop come on
that's it that's [ __ ] it just so much
damage Bob's got a new move oh nevermind
karate chop cut it off [ __ ] karate chop
karate ha ha ha Burbank I've never
gotten that before oh yeah what you
gonna do now Bob controllin old campus
[ __ ] tell ya Oh
karate chop karate time you got [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Betty's mother my god you got nothin a
Baba conflab get [ __ ] ah Bob the
greatest character of all time Bob may
be fat but he is also fat thank you very
much everyone I'm so I'm starting to get
the tekken bug this is [ __ ] really fun
I'm gonna get a new controller
oh that pan that doesn't have any
nipples it's a lay apart whatever oh
[ __ ] he's not that he's not dead he said
the box line [ __ ] he's so bad he's so
fast
bob is fat everyone Bob is fat well I'm
never gonna play this again because I'm
on a [ __ ] roll sir thank you very
much thank you Joe Myra got it okay this
is fun I might I might do another one of
these I really enjoy a fighting game
it's something I never used to play at
all as a kid oh yeah leave it like you
enjoyed let me know if you want more and
it's always Bobby's fan